[Music]  Octavia Spencer hidden fences the  fallout over the hidden fences flub at  the Golden Globes continues when the  mistake confusing hidden figures and  fences was made not once but twice on  Sunday you're nominated for hidden  fences  I had an error in the night which I have  to apologize for Monday morning Jenna  Bush Hager fought back tears on the  Today Show as she apologized for the  on-air snafu I've interviewed cast from  both of the movies and if I offended  people I am deeply sorry it was a  mistake because I'm y'all know I'm not  perfect  I am authentic but but a human and what  I didn't want to do is make anybody feel  lesser than who they are  ETS Kevin Frazier got the moonlight cast  to weigh in backstage after their big  win including Janelle Monae who also  stars and hidden figures we all win one  advances we are living  [Music]  you